-Jimmy!
-That is exactly what --
That's the perfect segue
into my first question,
you celebrating like that.
I have a picture that I saw of
you at the U.S. Open.
-Oh, yes.
-Look at you celebrating
for Serena.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that a real celebration
or is that just a one-up
for Instagram?
-Oh, no, that's like
the realest --
That's like the most Serena...
-Really?
-...expression ever.
Like, when I watch her, even on
the couch, I'm like that.
-Really?
-Yeah, it's crazy.
-You're like, "Yeah, come on!"
-Yeah.
I mean, also,
you know what helps?
You know the U.S. Open drinks?
The melon ones with the little
tennis ball melons?
-A couple of those?
-Yeah, 'cause when I get there,
I'm a wreck.
Like, I'm so anxious.
-Because you're friends
with Serena.
-Yeah, so, I, like, take it
really personally.
I think that she can really feel
that I'm there supporting her.
She has no idea.
-No, but she does --
-Until after the game,
she doesn't really know
I'm there, probably.
-You're very loud.
-Very loud.
-Yeah, you're a great friend
to have.
So, this last match
you're watching,
you're just like,
"Come on, bud."
-Yeah. I mean, no, just, like,
when -- when --
you know, if she was serving
one way or --
-You know.
-And then it just happens,
and I can feel her feel it,
then, oh, it's just the best.
-You were saying you text her
and she'll get back to you,
like, during --
-Oh, yeah, during the game.
She gets back to me
during the game.
No, no, no. I just try to send
like a supportive message.
And you're like,
"She's not going to respond.
Like, "She's in the U.S. Open
this week."
-Well, what do you do? If you
hang out with Serena Williams,
what would you do with Serena?
-Karaoke, mostly.
-Really?
-Serena is a karaoke,
like, legend.
-Really?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love knowing this.
What is her go-to?
Do you know what her song is?
-I can't.
You'll have to ask her.
She's on next week, right?
-She's coming on.
-You'll have to ask her
what her go-to song is.
-What is yours?
-Mine goes a lot of
different directions.
Really depends on the night.
I try to take it --
keep the vibes going.
But sometimes I'll throw in like
a Disney song here and there.
Swear to God.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I can see you doing that.
-Like, "I just can't wait
to be king."
-That's your jam?
"Lion King" is your jam?
-Sometimes I'll throw it
in there, yeah.
If I'm feeling it.
-I don't know if I say this
every time you're on the show,
I love your voice.
-You do?
-Yeah. I think you should do
a movie, or an animated movie,
or a podcast,
or something like that.
-Thank you.
-Yeah. I just love it.
I'm always like,
"Oh, what a great voice."
-Oh, I appreciate that.
I feel like you're probably
one of the only people
that thinks that.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no way, no way.
-Thanks, Jimmy.
But it means the most to me.
Like, obviously -- you know.
-I hear a lot of voices.
-You have one of the best voices
of all time.
-[ Laughs ] I don't, but --
-He does, he does, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No.
So, here's why -- one of
the reasons why I love you.
Last time I was talking to you,
you said,
"I'm working on
this clothing brand."
-Mm-hmm.
-And I go, "Oh, yeah.
You should do this."
Like, Gigi Hadid just come out
with your --"
and you go, "I know,
but I'm actually doing it
the right way.
I want to make sure
it's perfect."
This was years ago.
-Thanks.
-I mean, a lot work
goes into this stuff.
-I mean, you know, I think that
it was the next natural step
for me was to start
a clothing company.
And I felt a lot of pressure
for a few years to do that.
Whether that be from a deal or,
you know, people on my team.
And I was like, "Look, I'm just
going to take my time and --
I don't need to do a fast
fashion company just because,
you know, the offer is there
and whatever."
So, I want to the take my time
and look at my wardrobe
and think about something that
would feel genuine for me
to make and also for people to
see that coming from me and know
that it does come from something
that I care about.
And cashmere -- Yeah.
-You're wearing it tonight.
-I'm wearing it tonight.
This is the coziest
I've ever been on TV.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, this is great.
-You really are.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You were saying it's called --
Guest in Residence is the label.
What's the meaning behind
the name Guest in Residence?
-Guest in Residence.
Well, to me, Guest in Residence
is someone like Jimmy,
who walks into every room with
a warmth and a sense of comfort
in themselves that they're ready
to take on the world
around them,
have wonder about the person
in front of them.
And that's just like
a cozy person to me.
So it kind of just felt like
this material
that could go do those things
with people.
And this, you know, has such
a sustainable quality to it,
this material, that I really
want to encourage
this generation to invest in
good quality pieces
and keep them for a long time
in their wardrobes
and then pass them down
to people they love.
And, yeah, you know,
it is a luxury item.
I don't need people to buy
10 sweaters a year.
But I want to encourage thinking
about what you're consuming.
-You were saying what inspired
you, one of the reasons that --
Was it your mom bought you
a sweater
when you first moved to
the city?
-Yeah, yeah.
When I came to New York,
it was a crazy winter
my first year of college.
It was, like, the coldest winter
ever.
There was one winter,
the snow was piled up
on both sides of the street.
Like, you couldn't even cross
the street.
-You couldn't even see
the trash bags.
-You couldn't even --
Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
So, I took a sweater
from each of my parents
for this,
you know, first big winter of
mine.
And it kind of was this piece
that I would, you know,
one, you never get rid of it
because it means something.
It kind of becomes this heirloom
that you learn to take care of
and that has this really nice,
nostalgic feeling to it.
And I just felt --
-Yeah.
So, everyone on your Christmas
list, get Guest in Residence,
and get one special one
and just hand it down
for years and years to come.
It is the softest, by the way.
-Oh, Jimmy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh, I love it.
-I'm wearing the socks.
-Oh, the socks as well.
We got it all going down.
Let me throw out
a pair of socks.
You're going to love
one of these.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guest in Residence. Split them.
Hand them -- One wears one sock.
One wears the other.
-I'm throwing some.
-You got one?
We're throwing out socks,
people.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're throwing out socks.
That is Guest in Residence
right there.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Gigi Hadid!
Guest in Residence.
We'll be right back
with Blake Shelton, everybody.
Come on back!